so hello everyone
my name is from
and uh
my co-speaker is hui and we represent
the floating cheeses project
in this conference
uh full disclosure we are not data
scientists
so our view on
the
research software might not be
entirely accurate and also
our purpose here is not to communicate
our project but to communicate ideas
around it
so first
we will try to have a common
understanding on
these research software so
as we understand it the purpose of
visual software
is first to have a replication which
means
we try to
have
some tooling to
operate on a data that will always give
the same exact same result every time
this way
people
who try to replicate our results or read
our work can
uh
how to put it
they can
verify our work and verify our thinking
and logic among with the way that we
analyze data
in addition
uh
the rich software is also for
reproduction so
production is
slightly similar to replication
but
we don't use the exact same machine not
the exact same software not the exact
same environment
but in the similar method
we still get the
same answer from the
uh similar set of data
and last uh this is
considered to be the most important one
is to reuse and remix
of the software
we view it as
the way for the research software to be
used in
future experiments by
the next
scientist that
are interested in the research
because science is
well at least the way you view it is
continuous continuous
development and
without the reusing the research
software
um
now future researcher will end up
reinventing the wheel and
we will not get the progress that we
want
so these are the requirements for
the visual software and well we are
concerned with
how to
best facilitate researchers for the
tasks
in the scope of this talk we will only
consider the
dependencies management uh and
the final
delivery of the research software and
with that
currently there are
currently there are two ways uh one
uh
to get the
uh
libraries one is through python
packaging tools and in the scope of the
pi data conference we
try to
target the python threshold software
and the other way is containers so with
python packages
then
for replication then it's pretty much
always
work uh of course if the machine is
different then
no you will not get the exact same
answer
but with lock it almost ensure that the
operating system and the
architecture is the same
reproduction
is mostly the same
but without locking their dependencies
there's a risk of getting
dependency not
resolved in the exact same version and
we can have slightly different behaviors
but
it is possible to work around them
although uh it's my worth
note that
[Music]
with
future releases of software many things
might change and
the
the libraries that are resolved after
uh installing libraries can end up not
working well together
for reuse and remix
it's
still on the same track uh it might work
but
there's a high chance that the
dependencies on different ritual
software that we try to use together
might not work together at all they
might have uh
they might declare
completely conflicting versions or that
they
do not work but we do not
have the information on that and
it's rather
uh not optimal
um so to
discuss a little bit further on
the dependency management we would like
to
view on the
upstream and downstream perspectives so
the upstream developers are those who
create
the libraries who
also the developer of the final
applications or software like the
researchers and in here we
illustrate them
as
the
the smaller rivers in blue
and the downstreams are the ones that do
final packaging do the integration of
uh the all the libraries and the final
application to make sure that everything
work well together and we denote them as
the purple is red in here
so from the industrial perspective they
can see all of the software
and how they work together but from
upstream they only see fraction of the
picture
and of course
with all that after all the packaging we
can give them to the users the one who
will be running or
re-running our software
so for
option developers the only thing that
you really need to do is to write good
software and we know that we do
and that's all
and pin independencies is
really really not encouraged because
the more restrictions you make the less
likely that we can
we can make your software work together
with others
plus for registries like ipi and
anaconda
they are centralized registries and they
can have downtime
at any
point and the single point failures can
cost you time and effort
so with containers replication is
intended usage so it would work really
well
but for reproduction uh
if you give the complete
instruction to rebuild it like a
dockerfile
then it might work but
the complexity could hinders the
ability to
reproduce the container without the
exact copy
and we also have inherent problem with
the registries because that's how the
software downloaded for use and remix
then you can't really use
container software together at the
library level of python
so hi everyone um we and
so we propose a
solution to the problem
we call it a floating key
and
this this are python binary distribution
and we uh
it is platform unique and singly
versioned
from casual
switzerland
and
it is backed by ipfs
and they are often found in flying
circus
so thanks to being
singly version and platform unique which
means given a version and a platform you
will have only one version for each
package
it is easy to integrate and upgrade
other packages and
thanks to ipfs is also easy to
source the
household instance of
the
distribution and
the
floating cheese is orthogonal to
containers and it is not mean to replace
but to attach to pipi
and in fact we use
the wheels and the metadata from pipi to
write a package declaration with this
format
to
and
thanks to uh
thanks to these advantages we
you will find it's a pleasant experience
to replicate and reproduce as well as
reusing and remixing
so how do you use the wheels from
floating cheeses
firstly you
get a
civ from our release
for on this link and then you set up an
ipfs gateway
after that you configure bit to
uh to download the wheels from the link
the uh ips gateway after that
you
you can start using your packages
you can have the project by running a
mirror
by pinning the ipfs
cid and
and you can also contribute
to the project that links
by
by a package
like
declaring the packages
if you have any further questions you
can ask us
our mailing list or our magic room or
right after this speech
thank you for listening
so we have a short demo of how we will
try to use the floating cheeses in
production
so first
we
will have the cryptographically signed
tags here with the
cid ibfs cid they are content
identifiers
and if you open this
and they are
[Music]
they are the
pf the pep
3503
repository and you can use them
immediately with the
with pip
or any other client so what i use here
for instance is i
give the index url and i will be able to
install any package so for instance if i
want to install scipy
then it will download from it and
install normally and uh
with this cid we will ensure that ensure
also the cid of every
uh children inside of the repository so
you only need to pin the
parent repository and you would also pin
every single package inside of it
that's the general idea that we try to
convince
so instead of
pinning individual packages we can pin
the repository and this repository can
have upgrades and the upgrades will be
seamless from version to version
so i think it's time for q a now
okay this is a question from anna gut
do i understand correctly that you have
a copy of a specific version of a
repository and i'm just wondering how to
compare it to a
pip env
the first one yes you understand
correctly that is a
copy of a specific version of repository
the difference the from
a project like floating chases and
uh the automatically generated the
hashes in pip end is that
with photon changes the packages are
declared by human
which means that we have a downstream a
team of downstream
packagers that will declare and check if
the packages will well integrated with
each other
and
the dependencies
management will not
need to be handled by
the
packages users which means that they are
researchers or developers
they will just
get a
repository version and they are done
with it okay so
uh thank you phone and phone for the
presentation and now let's see if we
have the next speaker on the live thanks
a lot again
thank you
you